everybody's got to die
but this cemetery is full of people
who've died in their 20s 30s
40s and 50s and every one of them that
dies of natural causes has died of
nutritional deficiency disease
this is a blind spot for the medical
profession they don't get a single 30
seconds of training in nutrition
and as a result 90 of the people in this
graveyard have died long before their
genetic potential of 120 and 140.
i'm your host holly paloma our in studio
guest is dr
joel d wallick thanks for being here dr
wallace thank you holly it's great being
with you
you make a pretty bold statement there
when you say dead doctors don't lie why
do you say that
well holly americans are led to believe
by the medical profession
that there's no hope there's no cures
there's no preventions for
degenerative diseases such as heart
disease cancer
arthritis cataracts glaucoma diabetes
and as a result their life savings are
being cannibalized by the medical
profession
for simply band-aid treatments for what
i call physician-caused diseases and
again
all these diseases including alzheimer's
disease and cancer and so forth
are in fact preventable are in fact
treatable and
as a result i believe that the americans
have been misled more than any other
people they have actually the american
medical profession has killed more
americans with a single sentence
what's that than all of the foreign
armies that ever killed americans
and that sentence says you can get
everything you need from your four food
groups
and as a result the physician in america
doesn't take
vitamins and minerals as a group they
don't take supplements so they make a
great control group
for the rest of us and 85 percent of
americans do take supplementation in one
form or another maybe vitamin c or
vitamin e
or whatnot and
doctors if you look at them as a group
if you separate them out from the
general public if they knew what they
were talking about for health and
longevity
they should be healthier and they should
live longer i mean this is simple
fourth grade logic right sounds right
sounds logical and so
when you separate them out though you
find something very terrifying
the medical doctors in america their
average lifespan is 58
and the average lifespan for the average
american is 75.5 so you gain 20 years
statistically
simply by not going to medical school
let's talk a little bit about your
professional background
well actually it starts the wallet story
starts back when i was on a bee farm in
missouri
and as a teenager i noticed that we did
something special for those calves we
would grind up the feed the corn and the
beans and the hay and we would add
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
to that and this is some 50
plus years ago and we would make pellets
and we'd feed those calves and after six
to nine months we'd ship them off to
market
and butcher them and we ate out of those
very same fields as a family we'd saved
back five rows of corn
for the family we had a garden at the
end of the field where we grew our
tomatoes and squash and
carrots and beans and peas and whatnot
and we didn't do that same thing for
ourselves we didn't take vitamins and
minerals
for ourselves and we wanted to live to
be a hundred with no aches and pains
now that fascinated me so my dad of
course when when i'd asked him say hey
pops
how come we do all that for the calves
not for ourselves and being an old
missouri farmer he'd say things like
shut up boy
do as i say yes exactly don't ask
complicated questions
and so i went on to ag school at the
university of missouri and my major was
in animal husbandry nutrition
my minor was in field crops and soils
and i began to learn technical things
about how to grow the maximum yield in
terms of tons and bushels
per acre of ground with a simple
fertilizer called npk
and what that meant to nutrition for
animals and people
and i didn't get a real answer to my
basic question though until i went to
veterinary school again the university
of missouri
and what i learned was the reason why we
put all these vitamins and minerals and
trace minerals into animal feeds
is because we don't have insurance for
them we don't have blue cross blue
shield major medical hospitalization
medicare
or medicaid and if we were to use a
human health care type of system for
animals
it'd be sticker shock for everybody
holly the the hamburger would cost
people 275
a pound oh my yes that'd be a wake-up
call yes
and so we learned that we could keep the
cost of animal products such as meat and
eggs and dairy products
within the average means of an american
simply by preventing and curing diseases
with nutrition
now that fascinated me after graduating
vet school though i went to africa for
two years and got to work with marlon
perkins
oh yeah mutual of omaha sure wild
kingdom
hey you got it and uh that was a lot of
fun got to play frank buck for two years
tranquilizer gun and wander all over
africa catching i was an extra large
animal vet
because they taught me how to catch
elephants and rhinos and how to track
and
it's really not difficult to track a
herd of elephants so i would i wouldn't
imagine so they leave rather large
tracks
and so after two years of doing that
marlon sent me a telegram invited me
back to
missouri to work at the st louis zoo and
washington university in the botanical
gardens
because they'd gotten a seven and a half
million dollar grant to study
pollution and its effect in large
populations of animals and people
it was again some 30 plus years ago
before anybody really knew what all this
meant although they did identify
pollution or air water and food
and my job was to do autopsies of
animals that died
of natural causes to find out and a
species
was ultra sensitive to pollution which
we could use as an early warning system
a monitoring system
much like the old coal miners used to
use a canary oh okay the canary in the
mine thing
and to make a long story short after
some 12 years working on that project
and working in all the big zoos in the
united states
uh i had in fact done 17
500 autopsies of over 454 species of
animals
plus 3 000 human beings for a comparison
and again what i learned was very
frightening what i learned was that
every animal and every human being who
dies of
natural causes dies of nutritional
deficiency disease
oh really yes and i got excited about
this nutrition thing again
yeah and so what i did i wrote 75
scientific papers in veterinary journals
and medical journals and pathology
journals
contributed to eight multi-author
textbooks on the subject
uh wrote one of my own thousand pages
cost 140 bucks for medical students
and i got on 2020 with hugh downs and
geraldo before he got his nose broke for
the first time
and then was on every network tv 1700
newspapers lectured all across the
united states
i couldn't get anybody excited about
this finding that everybody dying of
natural causes died of a nutritional
deficiency disease
so i got frustrated enough i went back
to portland oregon went back to school
for four years and became a physician
and i got to use everything i learned
about veterinary nutrition
on my human patients it was no great
surprise to me that it just worked like
a charm
yes you can prevent diseases with
nutrition
and didn't take long when the word got
out hey this doctor wallet treats you
like a dog but you get better
so these people i mean the word got out
and hundreds and hundreds of people used
to call
every day and ask hey can i get some of
this veterinary nutrition advice right
and my wife and i started uh actually
putting a little pamphlet to try and
answer the comment questions
and that just generated more interest so
we finally had to come out with a book
which is now a bestseller called
let's play doctor let's play doctor
you've never heard that before
you haven't heard that and this book
actually teaches people how to use
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
to prevent and make significant progress
in treating
400 diseases it's the best investment in
their life there's a little book
let's play doctor and then by popular
demand
a another book came out and actually
is a add-on to that book let's play
docker it's called rare earth forbidden
cures talks about the 72 minerals
that are found in human tissues and
animal tissues and blood
uh 60 of which the minerals are actually
known to be essential
but you know when you read the the the
labels on
food they sure don't mention 72
different minerals or heavens no and
that's because our soils are depleted
and this is why we have so many problems
i see it okay
now again remember i said we used a very
simple fertilizer for over 100 years npk
it only takes about 10 years to deplete
the soils of the nutritional minerals
that animals and people need
we actually have 90 essential nutrients
that we need by definition essential
nutrient your body cannot make it
and number two if it's missing uh if any
nutrient is missing it's an essential
nutrient you get an average of
10 diseases so 10 diseases times 90
nutrients as 900 diseases are
preventable with proper supplementation
and 60 minerals times 10 is 600 diseases
that are actually caused by mineral
deficiency diseases again we're talking
about diabetes
and cancer and heart disease and
arthritis and so we're talking some
major major
diseases here that can be prevented with
nutrition how can the wealthiest
industry in the world with so much money
overlook simple nutrition
well holly nutrition is a blind spot for
the medical profession they don't get 30
seconds of nutritional training
you leave that to the nurses and the boy
scouts and moms and dads and things like
that
and as a result any time a disease
comes forth that is actually caused by a
nutritional deficiency they don't
recognize it everything today is caused
by genetics when you talk to the medical
person right
right well give us an example of
what diseases can be prevented by
nutrition
okay holly one of my favorite diseases
is arthritis because
75 percent of all americans over the age
of 50 get it in one farm or another and
there's not a single medical treatment
designed to fix it
aspirin doesn't fix arthritis and can
cause gastric bleeding and death
tylenol doesn't fix arthritis and can
result in and does result
in fifty thousand cases of kidney
failure year 5000 of which
are severe enough they require kidney
transplant ibuprofen advil don't fix
arthritis and cause liver damage and two
to five percent of the users
methotrexate and gold shots don't fix
arthritis and can result in bone marrow
depression
and in birth defects in pregnant women
who are using the methotrexate
and prednisone and cortisone don't fix
arthritis
and they do cause depression of the
immune system as well
as accelerate mineral loss from the
bones and teeth and other
organs and tissues and when these
over-the-counter and prescription
medications don't work anymore
to reduce pain and inflammation the only
thing left medically for an arthritis
suffer
is joint replacement surgery they need
new hips new
knees fusion vertebrae together new
shoulders
and you're actually becoming a bionic
person for hundreds of thousands of
dollars
and really all you need is about 10 to
20 cents a day worth of a few minerals
to actually prevent or reverse this
trend now
let me tell you that as a veterinarian i
never felt comfortable
with my patients you know i'm a
physician and a veterinarian so i never
felt comfortable with my patients being
shunted off to a surgeon to get a joint
replaced
and so i looked into my veterinary
background and said well is there
something we do nutritionally for
animals to prevent and cure arthritis
and sure enough
there is uh we have nutritional formulas
for pigeons and turkeys and dogs and
cats and pigs and sheep and horses and
cows and lions and tigers and beers and
there's oh my god
and we actually learned how to prevent
and cure arthritis in animals with
nutrition
so i pulled these together and adapted
them
to human use and what i call dr
wallach's pig arthritis formula
is one of the 400 formulas that you find
in let's play doctor there's actually
400 formulas of how to prevent and
make better if you will i can't use to
cure words specifically directly for a
particular disease but i can say you
could get 100
better but in a medical book you can if
you have a vitamin c deficiency
you can give vitamin c and cure the
vitamin c deficiency so you can look in
those terms
but anyway dr wallach's pig arthritis
formula is very simple
use five ounces of calcium enriched
orange juice a half ounce of knox
gelatin
and one ounce of a liquid colloidal
mineral and one ounce of a liquid
colloidal mineral vitamin amino acid mix
and this mixture together is what i call
dr wallick's pig arthritis from
and i've really literally seen 10 000
people over the last
five years who have regrown cartilage
and bone either even though they had
bone bone arthritis their physician said
the only thing left for you was to
get a joint replacement surgery costing
you hundreds of thousands of dollars
that's right holly another example is
heart disease the number one killer
of americans this is another
physician-caused disease is actually by
erroneous and maybe even criminal
nutritional advice given by the medical
profession
let me give you a very specific example
you may remember this in april of 1993
reggie lewis
the captain of the boston celtics 27
year old
athlete he didn't have a gram of fat on
his body i mean this guy was perfect
shape
collapsed during a playoff game with the
charlotte harness was diagnosed very
accurately and very
quickly with a disease called
cardiomyopathy
the medical treatment of choice for
cardiomyopathy if you
survive the initial heart attack is a
heart transplant for 750 thousand
dollars
and the boston celtics because reggie
was a 65 million dollar
contract athlete hired the top 12
cardiologists in the whole world
and they named them the dream team of
cardiology you may remember that sure
and they were given a million dollars
each to refer all their patients out to
other doctors
and devote their whole time to saving
reggie they didn't take 50
of their million dollars and give it to
a medical student or pre-med student to
go to the library and ask the medical
computers
what are all the known causes of
cardiomyopathy now if they'd had done
that
the medical computers would have said
there's only one known cause
cardiomyopathy and what's that it was
discovered in 1957 in animals
it was proven in human beings in 1972 by
a double-blind crossover study with 45
000 human subjects
the results of which was published in
every medical journal in the world no
less than six times
the only known cause of cardiomyopathy
heart disease is a selenium deficiency a
trace mineral deficiency
now not one of those members of the
dream team of cardiologists
gave reggie lewis 10 cents worth of
selenium
all he did was argue in bicker who was
going to be rich and famous during the
heart transplant or installing the
pacemaker whatever decision they made
and as a result three months after his
initial attack while they were bickering
and arguing
reggie lewis died at age 27 july 28 1993
of his second cardiomyopathy heart
attack now if you wait long enough
justice has a way of coming around
remember my hobby is dead doctors don't
lie collect obituaries of doctors who
die
what i call malignant dumb reasons these
are nutritional deficiency diseases
the chief the head of this dream team of
cardiologist a doctor
w thomas nessa 48 years old
a year and a half after reggie lewis
died of cardiomyopathy guess what dr
nessa died from a cardiomyopathy heart
attack
because he wouldn't take the
supplementation that contained the
selenium
so he died of the same thing and why
would you want to do
anything that a doctor told you who
lives to be 48 10 years short of the
average
for doctors 30 years short for the
american public
i would think that they wouldn't know
what they were talking about exactly and
so when you sit back and you look at
this
it is very frightening you do not want
to take advice from doctors on chronic
degenerative diseases
because they have absolutely no training
in these areas another example
would be high blood pressure something
as simple as high blood pressure they
have the malignant dumb belief
that high blood pressure has to do with
salt consumption
the first thing that a farmer rancher
husbandryman puts out for his livestock
cattle and sheep is a salt block nice so
they think that the american public is
malignant dumb or dumber than a cow
because uh what happens is a cow can
have all the salt she wants
there's no veterinarian out there for
eighty dollars a visit saying how bossy
you have to restrict yourself restrict
yourself no
but we we do that as americans and again
the medical profession believes that you
can prevent high blood pressure by
restricting salt and as a result of this
advice 550 people in chicago
died in july during the heat wave
because they had a salt deficiency they
were given a salt restricted diet
that's why i mean think of all the
millions of people who live in the
deserts of the world and they don't die
and they don't have air conditioning and
they don't have air it's a
simple salt deficiency now they also
believe that you can
actually treat high blood pressure by
restricting salt and
the government spent 30 million dollars
in a study was called the sodium task
force
and they actually looked at salt
restriction as a way of controlling high
blood pressure
they found it had absolutely nothing to
do with controlling or preventing high
blood pressure by restricting salt
in fact high blood pressure is due to a
deficiency of the mineral calcium the
simple
symptom of calcium deficiency is high
blood pressure
osteoporosis certain forms of arthritis
foot and leg cramps insomnia muscle
twitches
and a whole litany of other things
including bell's palsy and
spinal stenosis and so forth all these
are calcium deficiency disease remember
ten diseases for each nutrient that's
deficient
right and so you shouldn't be too
surprised then that doctors don't know
these things because they don't get
30 seconds worth of nutrition and we
could go on and on alzheimer's disease
is another one they give you the
erroneous advice
give up cholesterol 75 of your brain
weight is pure cholesterol
right you only make a third of your
daily needs right because your body
makes some of those
a little bit now if you give up all your
cholesterol and
75 percent of your brainwaves pure
cholesterol after a period of years on a
zero cholesterol diet what's the first
thing that goes holly
probably the old squash not your hips
it's not your hips it's the head ahead
and so this is why i say that all these
diseases are physician caused diseases
heart disease number one killer cancer
the number two killer
diabetes number three killer alzheimer's
disease today the number four killer of
americans over the age of 65
all of these are physician-caused
diseases they're preventable
by the correct approach to nutrition the
correct approach to supplementation with
the essential
90 nutrients including the 60 essential
minerals
and certainly heart transplants and and
all their medications and vaccines
haven't uh increased longevity in fact
in america
the lifespan has dropped from 78.5
in 1990 to 1995 at 75.5 we've dropped
and we would think
that with all of the information out
there that we should be going up even
higher
exactly i'll give you one more scary
thought here oh
the russian the russian lifespan has
dropped seven years
in the last five years it was 64
five years ago before the breakup of the
soviet union once the soviet union broke
up
it has now dropped their lifespan is now
57 they've lost more than 11 percent
of their lifespan in just a few years
and the director of the studies on this
from the university of london
came out and said there's no historical
precedence for this
uh-huh we know the reason what kinds of
things should people be looking for
um if if if they're looking for signs of
mineral deficiency obviously we don't
have time to cover all of the diseases
here today
well the earliest signs are recognizable
by everybody even medical doctors if
they pay attention holly
right say for instance white gray or
silver hair is the first symptom
of a copper deficiency of course this is
a cosmetic thing to the average person
but it's more sinister than that
because a serious copper deficiency
results in a breakdown of the elastic
fibers and arteries
which results in a aneurysm which will
rupture you die suddenly from a copper
deficiency
and of course a selenium deficiency
which can lead to cardiomyopathy heart
disease talked about firstly yep yep the
first symptoms are these little age or
liver spots that people get on the back
of their hands
and then of course you have things like
low blood sugar which are the first
symptoms of a chromium and vanadium
deficiency
which will lead to diabetes right and
then of course you get
arthritis which is the first symptom of
a calcium
actually even before that you get
perhaps foot cramps or muscle twitches
insomnia high blood pressure these are
all early warning symptoms
of calcium deficiency which leads to
more sinister things like
arthritis and osteoporosis now
should i go out to the to the store
health food store
grocery store or whatever and just buy
any vitamin or mineral out there
it's not quite that simple unfortunately
and you did what most people do you talk
about vitamins there's actually 90
essential nutrients which include
60 minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential
amino acids and 3 essential fatty acids
and fortunately for human beings over
the thousands of years we've been around
plants our food plants grains fruits and
vegetables can manufacture
vitamins and amino acids and fatty acids
because these are carbon chains
the things we have problems with are
minerals actually vitamins won't even
work without minerals
yeah and nothing works without minerals
your body chemistry won't work without
minerals we need them as cofactors
plants cannot manufacture these these
are only available
if there's minerals in the soil which
the plant grows in there's actually a
senate document u.s senate document 264
which was published in 1936 60 years ago
60 years ago which says there's no
longer any nutritional minerals left in
our farm and range soils
oh so this is why we have all these
degenerative diseases in america not
because we have a prednisone deficiency
or a penicillin deficiency and there's
basically three types of minerals you
have to be concerned with one is the
earliest form of supplementation that
goes back
10 000 years these are elemental
minerals like clays and
limestone and oxides and oyster shell
and eggshell
these are only three to five percent
available to the average adult
then we had an improvement of these to
chelated minerals which we add the amino
acids and proteins
to the metallic atom it increases the
absorbability to 40
for adults but the way that animals and
people were designed to absorb minerals
holly
is in a colloidal form now we get
colloidal minerals from plants plants
have the ability
to take metallic minerals from the soil
convert them in their own tissues using
the sun's energy and
photosynthesis converting these
elemental minerals to colloidal minerals
and then of course they use them for
their own chemical reactions
and we eat the plants and get some
however u.s senate document 264 says
no longer any minerals left in our soil
right we don't have them all in there we
don't have them in there and of course
as a result we get all these mineral
deficiency diseases
now again being sort of an average dumb
farm boy i kind of
look at the reality of things and
there's no less than six cultures on
earth
who actually lived to be 120 to 140 with
no
degenerative diseases they were written
up in the national geographic january of
1973 january 1973 a special issue on
longevity
and these people even though they're
different races different religions and
different cultures
all have a common denominator they all
irrigate with glacial milk
which is comprised of 60 to 72 minerals
from the ground up rocks that the
glaciers are on
they irrigate with these and as a result
these 60 to 72 minerals go back in the
soil
their plants get these minerals and are
rich with these colloidal minerals
as a result they don't have diabetes
they don't have cancer they don't have
heart disease
they don't have arthritis they don't
have glaucoma cataracts
and they don't have a single doctor
clinic
or hospital you know there are a lot of
a lot of fads out there um you know
everything from
oat bran to to to fish oils how do we
how do you distinguish those how do you
get past that to get the minerals that
you need
well the first thing you have to realize
very quickly is that whenever the
medical profession comes out with
something new
that is the cause of all things when
they first discovered bacteria
hundreds of years ago bacteria caused
everything from insanity to
infertility and then it was the viruses
and they had all these
culture techniques for viruses and
everything was caused by viruses from
insanity to infertility and cancer
and now it's genetics they have this
technique for genetics everything is
genetics
right and so the first thing a person
has to do is get information so they can
be aware of what's going on
just like these self-help books how to
change your oil how to put roofing on
and so forth
don't give your total responsibility for
your health to a doctor a nurse or a
candlestick maker or anybody else do it
yourself first
and you'll be much safer you'll save
yourself an enormous amount of
unnecessary misery
a gob of money and you'll add many
healthful years to your life and the
best place to start
is with let's play doctor that
best-selling book that book of years
which teaches you how to use vitamins
and minerals and herbs and alternative
therapies for over 400 diseases
so the four food groups don't work don't
work the soil's depleted
we've been getting wrong information
from doctors who live 20 years less than
we do how do we get on the right track
well the next thing a person has to do
once they get information number one you
got to get information
observe the early warning symptoms such
as the gray hair and the liver spots
low blood sugar high blood pressure foot
cramps muscle twitches
and then you have to take action and
here's where you want to make sure that
you take in all 90 essential nutrients
including the 60 minerals
16 vitamins 12 essential amino acids and
3 essential fatty acids
dr wallick's pig arthritis formula
contains 87 of the 90 known essential
nutrients
and of course the only way to get this
is by coming to our free
seminars and also you can get a hold of
the
us senate document 264. you get a hold
of the books
let's play doctor and you get a hold of
the books rare earth forbidden cures
again by calling this 800 number
participating in these free
seminars call the 800 number it's our
800 number well dr wallach i really
appreciate you being with us today it's
been very informative
just remember everybody dead doctors
don't lie
[Music]
thank you for viewing this presentation
and remember to contact the person that
sent this to you
for more presentations and books that go
into greater detail
go to doc wallockmedia.com and be well
these statements have not been evaluated
by the fda
these products are not intended to
diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease
the opinions expressed in this
informational program
are the express opinions of joel d
wallick bsdvmnd
are not a replacement for proper medical
advice and treatment
in all cases we recommend you contact
your physician directly
regarding any medical conditions